- Christie, you posted this on Instagram
last month.
It goes against my better judgment
to acknowledge haters
and conspiracy theorists
but because this involves
my precious daughter
I'm setting the record straight.
So tell us what needed to be set straight,
other than your bones that were broken,
and why are people meeting?
- I, what I mean
- They thought that this was a plan
- Yeah
- First of all, you'd be
the mother of the year
to break bones
(audience applause)
to get your daughter, like, if that's true
get it.
- Well, no, they thought,
this person thought,
that Dancing with the
Stars, this amazing show
that's been on on all these years
is going to lie, that
Cedars Sinai is going to lie
and go along with it, I
mean its so ridiculous
- Doesn't it make just so mad?
- Well at first I wasn't
even going to respond,
but you know what, like any mom out there
when it's your child, you
get a little riled up.
It's just indicative of
what's going on right now.
I just feel like in America,
we just need to love each other more
(audience applause)
- I literally have a tattoo
that says love them more.
Because I feel like,
that's from childhood,
somebody said that
because people were mean,
and I was like why are people so mean
and I asked, and I was at church,
and somebody, a really cool
pastor was like, you know
people who weren't loved
enough, that's why they're mean
so you need to love them more,
because they don't even know
how to reciprocate the feeling,
or feel it, or you know.
So it is true, love really
does heal a lot of things.